[music]
>> Many a time you have to use your brain
how to create
that scenario where you can convey to
him which is yours open. One is talking
talking talking oh
this person talks a lot. Comes from here
and goes from here.
When you talk and when people are paying
attention is a technique.
When people listen to you when you're
talking, that's a technique.
So in one to one dawa, one is you go and
just
overpower him. Listen listen to me
listen to me listen but it will not have
effect.
An effective dai is that
who convinces the person
makes the person
to give his time to him to learn about
Islam.
This was in short about forms of dawa.
We touched on the media which some will
cover later on. We touched on direct on
individual level. The main details of
public speaking will do in the next
inshallah three two days. We'll have a
short question answer session because we
are running behind schedule.
We will just speak for a few minutes.
Have the question answer session. Anyone
has any questions related to the topic
only?
Anything out of the topic we can discuss
later on.
Any question what I spoken in this talk?
If you have any questions raise your
hand.
Yes brother, let the microphone come to
you.
As-salamu alaykum Dr. Zakir Naik. Wa
alaykumu s-salam wa rahmatullahi wa From
the beginning until today you when you
talk in a public speaking, you do not
use PowerPoint.
You
begin out from your memory your
memorization.
So I have an habit for your hundred of
lectures I did with the help of
PowerPoint. Until to one level without
help of PowerPoint I couldn't be more
innovative in my speech. Please advise
me doctor.
The brother said that
I spoke in yesterday today without
anything from memory no PowerPoint. I
mean I'm using power power here. Even my
point is here.
Help of Allah alhamdulillah but your
power is different my power is
different.
You might have noticed
in this two days itself for one and a
half days
that sometime I was speaking with notes
in my hand. You saw that.
Now
you saw in the morning I kept the notes
down and then I spoke.
Rules and regulation had my notes in
hand.
You could see the difference in my
speech. World of a difference.
You see the modulation that I've got
without notes.
You see how free I am.
Did you notice?
Did you notice that no you may not have
noticed it. When I was speaking yes I
was impactful even while carrying the
notes but I know it is only a small
percentage of my presentation skills.
Because my presentation skills were
stuck in the paper.
But now because I was talking to you and
I wanted to be in line with you this is
the training program. The only time I
ever use notes
is in a training program where it's a
point form note given I don't want you
to write down.
Or maybe in a debate when I've jotted
down something otherwise
the impact is much better.
Which we'll deal inshallah tomorrow and
day after tomorrow. You said that
PowerPoint has its limitation or
PowerPoint is outdated. Again, it was at
one time.
One of my brother-in-law
even he'll be coming here. He's a
specialist in training.
He's a specialist in training on a
management level.
He'll be coming one of the days I
requested him.
He's very busy travels in different
parts of the world. He's expert in
training all Singapore, Switzerland and
he's working in a very top level company
I don't want to reveal that now. And at
that time when I did the first training
program, he had a session on ancillary
aids which I think he'll be taking on
next Saturday.
The coming Saturday 26th he'll be having
a session on ancillary aids.
At that time he was telling me the power
of PowerPoint. But yet he knew the power
of my PowerPoint Allah's PowerPoint is
much better. Now all the notes have
become obsolete.
All his notes what he gave have become
obsolete. He has new notes, correct?
But most of my notes what were
applicable alhamdulillah
16 and a half years back when I revised
it
almost all more than 95% was correct.
Maybe I spoke about audio cassette
obsolete but the techniques of public
speaking are the same.
This is the core.
What do you learn now? PowerPoint is
you know what you see behind you.
Something which is new in the market.
I asked people who have been on the
stage and many people raised their
hands.
You'll come to know you were wrong when
we deal with that.
You were wrong.
Partly two were right because they have
twisted some of it. We'll deal with that
when we come. I don't do talk about You
thought that you have have been on such
a stage before. You have not.
We'll deal with that when we come
to dawa through satellite inshallah.
Technology we have to be up to date as
dais.
So now technology is changing
alhamdulillah. It has its own pros and
cons but this method
I don't know anyone who has used
PowerPoint in front of a million people.
I don't know.
Do you know of anyone?
Who has used PowerPoint in front of a
million people live?
I don't know of any speaker in the world
alhamdulillah who has gathered a million
people for his own lecture alone. Yes
there have been conferences where many
speakers come and they come for the
organization and that's different. I'm
talking for individual lecture.
I have not heard of anyone alhamdulillah
gathering a million people but with the
help of Allah subhana wa ta'ala. With
Allah's PowerPoint it's possible
inshallah. Is there any other question?
Any question on this topic? Yes brother
that is.
In reality when you're meeting a person
in real, right?
>> Yes. Uh yeah. So this is a bit connected
because I'm sure of where there's a
thing called meetup uh which is very
popular in Europe and America where they
organize events on like different things
like jogging and like debating and like
different topics and people meet up. So
if I'm going to one of those events that
that events usually has a lot of
uh non-Muslims. So how can I do dawa for
example if I'm going to a meetup where
they're talking about uh you know like
uh health and well-being.
If I'm going to an event to any event
whether it's a festival whether it's a
meetup whether it's organized by the
social media and if it's talking about
health.
See now
you have a thousand things you can talk
about health.
In your hard disk
you have to try and retrieve
what do I know of health related to
Islam? So I will tell that the best way
to be healthy is
to offer salah five times a day. And
then I'll go on the lecture of salah the
scientific benefits.
People expect that okay let's do jogging
in the morning let's do weightlifting
and let's do pumping and all. Now I give
a talk on salah the scientific benefits.
I don't intend doing that now but you
can go on the YouTube type salah the
programming to righteousness go to the
scientific aspects. I've given you
various benefits.
What can you benefit? Normally your
blood flows less to the brain. When you
do sujud there's more blood flowing into
the brain. The more blood flows into
your skin you have less chance of having
chilblains. When you're doing sujud all
the bronchial tree the secretion they
drain out. Person having sinusitis
if he does sujud the sinuses drain out.
The talk is big. I'm just trying to give
highlights. So I would give a talk on
the health benefits of offering salah.
Though we Muslims don't offer salah for
health benefits. This is the side dish.
For us the biryani is to thank Allah.
It's a commandment of Allah. We pray to
him. But this scientific benefit may
impress ah
Do they something like transcendental
meditation? 14 letter word you know.
Transcendental meditation. With
meditation longer and you pay through
your noses in the western countries. I
said this is my transcendental
meditation much better.
And I don't know you haven't heard it.
Who has heard my talk
on salah the programming to
righteousness the scientific benefits?
We have heard it. So we have to go to
your hard disk.
What do you have?
Then maybe if I'm going to a vegetarian
meet so I'll talk about the health
benefits of having non-veg.
That in the body 23 amino acids required
out of which eight are not present in
the body. They have to be given in the
external diet. Now these eight amino
acids are called as essential amino
acids and this can only be had if you
have non-veg food. So when I'm going to
a vegetarian meet which is getting more
and more popular even in the western
world and vegetarian health
consciousness there is no vegetable
available in the world which has all the
eight amino acids.
You want to talk about that?
Depending upon the situation, if the one
alcohol is being served in that party,
then I give a talk on alcoholism.
The material is there. You should know
you should go back to your hard disk.
What do I have?
I have limited capacity only
1 GB. But the 1 GB should be powerful or
1 TB.
Depends.
Go and retrieve what you have and say.
This is a style how to do impromptu
speech, how to do dawa, depending upon
what knowledge you have. If you keep on
increasing your knowledge,
and increase the way you can use it in a
variety of ways. My knowledge is very
little.
But the ability to use that little
knowledge in different ways is an art.
Hope that answers the question.
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]
>> Allah.